so far we've managed to raise the
profile of issues in the country and
internationally secondly we've managed
to campaign on the ground through
defiance campaigns through
demonstrations strikes riley's so that
we can put pressure on the regime of
robotic gap in our country so that we
can demand conditions for free and fair
so we've achieved the propaganda whoa
around creation of conditions for free
and fair election secondly we have also
achieved always to working on building a
united front inspired by a single
candidate principle so that in any
election in our country we can present a
viable and electable opposition that can
win power against the dictatorship of
Robert Mugabe so creating conditions of
free and fair election we are working on
that with raising the profile of that
issue creating a united front to win
elections were working on that and we're
raising the profile at that matter and
also number three we have been crafting
the economic blueprints the economic
solutions that will allow our country to
move from poverty to the promised land
so this this is what defines our
achievements but there are achievements
that are part of work in progress
I think my experiences as a young person
who pursued history economics and
philosophy as a young man who was
involved in the activities in society
was a leader among his peers is someone
who studied science and technology that
has prepared me for the vision of
exposed around technology that G is
prepared me for the work that I'm doing
in terms of making a difference in other
words I do I'm a strong believer in the
need for a broader exposition for a
broader beg ground for you to be a good
leader every subject is important law
philosophy economics engineering
mathematics medicine so although you can
go to school and study all those
subjects it's important that as a leader
you have exposure and experience around
a broad spectrum of subjects and so I
think my background in terms of
extracurricular activity in terms of my
work in the community in America when as
a professor in this country I used to do
a lot of work in the black community as
to do public lectures it was always
important for me to be doing things
outside my field of training and so
those activities the Renaissance men
type of experience has prepared me for
my task which task is to make Zimbabwe a
peaceful democratic and prosperous
nation to make Africa a peaceful
democratic and prosperous continent
that's my mandate that's my desire the
chance of facing some wood in Zimbabwe
at the moment is that we are dealing
with a regime that is very corrupt that
is very the tutorial that is insensitive
and is not prepared to negotiate with
the people of Zimbabwe and I allow them
the scope for free and fair election
secondly we are also dealing with a
problem around African leaders we've
been duped by Mugabe Mugabe has framed
the debate in Zimbabwe
as a fight between Africans one end and
the imperialists Africans on one end and
the Blair's and bushes of the world to
the extent that then we in the
opposition becomes Stooges we become
puppets of the West so it's a challenge
of framing the debate it's a challenge
of perception and so we are trying as
the opposition in Zimbabwe to frame the
debates by saying we are an African
opposition part we are rooted in the
history of Africa in the history of
Zimbabwe were rooted in the history of
the liberation war we believe in
pan-africanism we believe in
anti-imperialism we believe that our
strategic partners globally at American
Japanese Europe but our political allies
at the NC cosas to SSCP and we seek to
delink Mugabe from the African so that
we understood in Africa so this
challenge that we have secondly the
other challenges around the economy most
African countries have gone to change
this bubble got independence 1980 right
now we're in a crisis in Zambia chiluba
got into power after kunda had been in
power for 27 years and she ended up
being Western calendar in Malawi Malusi
got into power after Banda and the loose
ended up being Western Banda meaningless
democratic change in Africa we don't
want that kind of change in Africa what
we wanted in Africa what one in Zimbabwe
is change that has got both form and
substance and this is a challenge
because sometimes we get caught up in
the fight for change and you do produce
change but that change will be changed
without substance so one of our
challenges is to say how do we make sure
that we not change comes in Zimbabwe
that change who have both form and
substance and so what it means is we
have to construct technocratic answers
we have to build technocratic capacity
among the leaders so that we now change
comes we can then make changes in the
economy around microeconomics around
science and technology
social policy HIV AIDS education so that
our change then becomes substantive the
other challenge is that the
international community has a very low
expectation of African countries they
are not in the mod or in the mood to
actually transfer technology to us they
don't see us as people who are spare to
be competitors the CSS people who are
meant to survive on eight men to survive
survive on donors and handouts so
convincing the international community
that what we seek is investment what we
seek is to become competitors is the
challenge that we have to do it as we
operate and work with our colleagues in
the West our colleagues in Africa our
colleagues in Asia those are some of the
challenges were grappling with but they
are not insurmountable we will succeed
the legacy of my party the legacy of my
colleagues and myself I don't believe in
individual legacy I believe in
collective legacy I believe in
generational legacy the legacy of my
generation in my country is that of
transforming Zimbabwe from poverty from
crisis to mix in Bob way a globally
competitive economy making Zimbabwe the
Singapore of Africa making Zimbabwe the
Switzerland of Africa if as a generation
we are able to make Zimbabwe the
Malaysia Singapore Africa in terms of
GDP per capita income business growth
economic empowerment of ordinary people
that would be our legacy in economic
legacy and economic mandate and at a
broader level we are seeking a legacy
for Africans if as Africans if as a
generation of Africans were able to make
African countries globally competitive
economy and also build regional
integration cedric acquires maghrib a
you do United States of Africa if we can
make
Africa is a continent economically
successful then that's the legacy we
seek as a generation our legacy is
around the economy our mandate is an
economic mandate that's the legacy we
sick we're sick and tired is Africans of
being beggars we're second tad of these
cycles of poverty and conflict we want
Africa to be a successful continent we
don't stick charity we don't seek aid
from anyone we want economic development
we want investment so that Africans can
be successful through economic
development through investment we are
saying is Africans we want to be in
charge of our natural resources we want
to make sure that we are producing
refined products so that we are selling
cars were selling computers to Europe to
America want to sell cars to Detroit and
not channel raw materials from Africa so
our legacy should be a legacy that makes
Africa economically successful through
value-added manufacturing through
beneficiation through the use of new
technologies wireless power wireless
telecoms Wi-Fi wimax through
biotechnology through clean energy we
have a unique opportunity actually to
use creative and cleaner technologies
than the West land advanced countries
with a unique opportunity to run where
others walked so that's the legacy we
seek in a revolution in the economy a
revolution driven by science and
technology in Africa so that Africans
can become global players that are
expected because of productivity that
are respected because of output we seek
to become competitors to America
competitors to Japan competitors to
Europe and North second class citizens
and a globalization that's all legacy